I have to bring up uh Joe Rogan I don't
know if you know who he is I do he's a
podcaster comedian fighting commentator
and
my now friend and Ivor mechton uh
believer too yes that is the question I
have to ask you about
uh he has gotten some Flack in the
mainstream media for not getting
vaccinated and when he got coveted
recently taken Ivermectin as part of a
cocktail of treatments the NIH actually
has a nice page on Ivermectin saying
quote there's insufficient evidence to
recommend either for or against the use
of ivermectin for the treatment of coven
19. results from adequately powered
well-designed and well-conducted
clinical trials are needed to provide
more specific evidence-based guidance on
the role of ivermectin in the treatment
of coven 19.
so let me ask why do you think there has
been so much attack on Joe Rogan and
anyone else that's talking about
Ivermectin when there's insufficient
evidence for or against
well let's unpack that first of all I
think the concerns about Joe are not
limited uh to his taking Ivermectin uh
much more seriously uh his being fairly
publicly negative about vaccines at a
time where people are dying
seven hundred thousand people have died
from covid-19 estimates by Kaiser or at
least a hundred thousand of those were
unnecessary deaths of unvaccinated
people and for Joe to promote that
further even as this uh pandemic rages
through our population is simply
irresponsible
so yeah the Ivermectin is just one other
twist obviously Ivermectin has been
controversial for months and months
um the reason that it got particular
attention is because of the way in which
it seemed to have captured the
imagination of a lot of people and to
the point where they were taking doses
that were intended for livestock and
some of them got pretty sick as a result
from overdosing on this stuff that was
not good judgment
the drug itself remains uncertain
uh there's a recent review that looks at
all of the studies of ivermectin and
basically concludes that it probably
doesn't work uh we are running a study
right now I looked at that data this
morning
uh in a trial called active six which is
one of the ones that my public-private
partnership is running we're up to about
400 patients who've been randomized to
Ivermectin or Placebo and should know
perhaps as soon as a month from now in a
very carefully controlled trial did it
help or did it not so there will be an
answer coming back to Joe
again I don't think the fact that he
took to Ivermectin and hoping it might
work uh is that big a knock against him
it's more the conveying of we don't
trust
what science says which is vaccines are
going to save your life we're going to
trust what's on the internet that says
Ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine really
do work even though the scientific
Community says probably not so let me
push back on that a little bit
so he doesn't he doesn't say let's not
listen to science he doesn't say the
vaccine don't get vaccinated
he says it's okay
to ask questions I'm okay with that how
risky is the vaccine for certain
populations what are the uh benefits and
risks there's other friends of Joe
and uh friends of mine like Sam Harris
who says if you look at the data
it's obvious that the benefits outweigh
the risks
and what Joe says is yes but let's still
openly talk about risks and he often
brings up anecdotal evidence of people
who've had
highly negative effects from vaccines
science is not done with anecdotal
evidence
and so you could infer a lot of stuff
from the way he expresses it but he also
communicates a lot of interesting
questions
uh and that's something maybe you can
comment on this
you know there's certain groups that are
healthy
they have uh they're younger they have
they exercise a lot they get the all you
know nutrition and all those kinds of
things he shows
skepticism on whether it's so obvious
that they should get vaccinated and the
same is he makes this he kind of
presents the same kind of skepticism for
kids
for young kids so
with empathy
and uh you know listening my Russian
ineloquent description of what Joe
believes what what is your kind of
response to that why should certain
categories of healthy and young people
still get vaccinated do you think well
first just to say it's great for Joe to
be a skeptic to ask questions we should
all be doing that but then the next step
is to go and see what the data says and
see if they're actually answers to those
questions so coming to healthy people
I've done a bunch of podcasts besides
this one the one I think I remember most
was a podcast with a worldwide wrestling
Superstar very nice he's about six foot
six and just absolutely solid muscle and
he got covet
and he almost died
and recovering from that he said I've
gotta let my
supporters know because you can imagine
worldwide wrestling fans are probably
not big
embracers of the need for vaccines
and he want he just turned himself into
a spokesperson for the fact that this
virus doesn't care how healthy you are
how much you exercise what a great
specimen you are it wiped him out
and we see that
you know the average person in the ICU
right now with covid-19 is under age 50.
I think there's a lot of people still
thinking oh it's just those old people
in the nursing homes that's not going to
be about me they're wrong and there are
plenty of instances of people who were
totally healthy with no underlying
diseases taking good care of themselves
not obese exercising who have died from
this disease
700 children have died from this disease
yes some of them had underlying factors
like obesity but a lot of them did not
so it's fair to say younger people are
less susceptible to serious illness kids
even less so and then young adults but
it ain't zero
and if the vaccine is really safe and
really effective
then you probably want everybody to take
advantage of that even though some are
dropping their risks more than others
everybody's dropping their risks some